[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday May 29th
I'm back on the odd days and I am here
in New York City searching for packing
supplies Hank you've turned us into
conservationists and as conservationists
we feel compelled to scour the streets
of New York City for moving boxes
instead of you know purchasing them
hey you may notice the slight difference
in the background of this video that's
because the Yeti and I have almost
finished packing all of our books
hold on I'll show you ah Oh Hank there
are many things that nerdfighters are
good at we're good at puzzles we're good
at being smart we're good at being
extraordinarily good looking but we do
not excel at lifting and lifting I'm
sorry to say is a very important part of
moving ok hold on I'm gonna get up and
show it to you yeah look at all the
books
Hank packing all of those books has sort
of sucked and it's caused my hamstrings
to snap into two but there has been one
advantage I've found two books that I've
been looking for for a long time the
first is called everything you need to
know about the goth scene in your pants
Hank here's what I'm wondering what kind
of goth scene are we talking about it
because I don't mind having people
listen to the cure inside my pants but
it's going to be really awkward to have
large armies massacring each other in my
pants
Hank you asked me while I was in the
Netherlands what we were going to do
about the paucity of evil female babies
that brings me to the second book I
found while packing the most evil women
in history in your pants Hank this book
has introduced me to several really
genuinely evil women but I am
particularly impressed by Queen Rana
Lobo Rena Valona Rena Valona queen Rena
Valona the first I like a couple of
things about Queen Rana Valona first I
like saying her name ran up alone I ran
up a loan or a novel onna read of Aloha
and second I liked the fact that she's
ran a Valona the first and that there
was never a random Valona the second
this reminds me of one of my other
favorite monarchs from history King Zog
the first of Albania Zog anyway Hank I'd
like to read you a quote about Queen run
of alona if this woman's rule lasts much
longer
Madagascar will be depopulated anyway
Hank I don't think we should have any
trouble at all finding an adequate
number of evil ladies to fill out the
evil baby orphanage I think that's all
from me Hank
I'll see you wait what's that come in
thank you very much yeah
from the desk of the Yeti hmm a year ago
last week John Green convinced this girl
to say I do
and his brother was you Hank thanks for
your warning but there's only so much
one yetiz wound can do and that number
is two Oh only one girl could ever stop
John Green from achieving his one
unmatchable dream I know that he will
stop before 19 if he wants to remain
married to me they may play ultimate
they may play darts but they needed play
soccer to win our hearts the only kind
of sporting team our kids will feel is a
competitively fierce game of skill they
needn't be numerous they needn't be huge
and the team they'll make is two-man
whoosh I could go on for many verses
more but the crucial lines are stated
here 2 for Hank I've got to tell you
tell you about the power I have Sarah
green may someday be a luge team making
machine Hey I'll see you tomorrow oh and
happy 26 birthday to Amy and happy 13th
birthday to Ann you guys are like half
each other's age so that's cool